hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on monster I'm not rolling it
and today we're gonna be talking about
the new event quest that just basically
came out and it's the Devil May Cry
collaboration with Monster Hunter and
we're gonna be showing you how to get
the armor we're gonna be showing you the
stats for the armor what it looks like
all the type of stuff how to get it and
what the monsters are going to be
involved in this quest as always like
the video if you guys do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I cover bait I cover
how-to guides solo guides for all the
monster stuff like that they're on my
channel how-to guides tips all the type
of good stuff for Monster Hunter world
so definitely keep on track and
subscribe for new like I said and went
that further ado let's get started so to
get the DMC armor the quest is called
Code Red is a start a quest and you have
to be HR 15 or higher in order to even
get this to pop up and it to fail you
basically have to either run out of time
or faint three times in the quest you
fight you know Daguerre on Anjanette
Rathalos anti Ostra in the arena so it's
a pretty difficult quest luckily you
don't have to fight all of them at the
same time or that would be very very bad
it's just one on one so it's not too bad
and just in case you are unaware the
monsters in this quest have less health
basically because all the monsters we
fought had lower helped which made the
fight easier because there were so many
because the way that Monster Hunter does
it is that the more monsters within the
quest the lower their overall help is so
it made like I said the quest a lot
easier to do I did it with a random
squad I queued up with me you can easily
do this solo if you want to unless the
order that they came out in is different
every time my order in specific was an
Jeanette Oda Garen rathalos and then tio
strove to end the quest like I said I
don't know if that's the straight order
and that's going to stay that way
or if it's random every time I suddenly
don't have guides on the other on all
the monsters I only have them on T Ostra
so if you're having trouble with TOS TRO
click the I on the top right and you
could be taken to mighty Oster guide to
help you out as well there's also other
solo guides as well for the other type
of Elder Dragons if you need those as
well fighting them really isn't too
difficult basically just look at your
monster field guide before you go into
the fight equip what you need it queue
up either solo or with a squad and then
just take out the monsters and kill them
no problem once the quest is over you
should be getting like of course
materials from the monsters you've
killed any gems as possible and then
also you'll be getting this thing called
the bread orbs which are used to craft
the armor now go to the smithy like I
said and craft the armor Dante's armor
require some form of materials whether
that be
sales or sinew or gems or whatever the
[ __ ] it happens to be of the for
monsters in the quest and red orbs which
you get from completing the quest and
specific the head has weakness exploit
and critical I with level one decoration
slot I will also show what the materials
in specific are on screen just the case
if you want to look at that as well
there's a lot of number so I'd rather
just showing on screen then go in-depth
with it
the body has evade window and critical
eye with a level three decoration slot
the arms have a vaild window and special
ammo boost with level three decoration
the torso has evade window as well and
latent power and a level three
decoration slot and the legs have
weakness exploit in to level one
decoration slots
I love critical eyes so I'm definitely
gonna be using the set especially the
headpiece I would have to say it's
probably one of my favorite and probably
the most useful event thing we've gotten
in my opinion that's because I'm a
sucker for critical eye and weakness
exploit maybe that could fit in your
build maybe it doesn't it's entirely up
to you and how your build works and all
the weapons but personally for me this
works perfect for my bill I'm definitely
gonna be grabbing the head and possibly
the body maybe even the legs but I got
to keep the nurger ghonte set so I can
get my agitated Onis and I'll take other
good stuff so I'll have to mix and match
as I go along
what's also is really cool is that I do
believe there is DMC music in the
background when you play and I've never
played a Devil May Cry game in my life
so I'm not entirely sure but there was
random music that wasn't Monster Hunter
s key and if I remember from the Megaman
quest
it did have Megaman music so I'm
assuming this was also Devil May Cry a
little background music that you maybe
do when you fight a boss or anything
like that which is really nice nod to
the series and it's really cool that you
get to use Dante's armor and as well
Dante also has a weapon specific for him
as well
is a charged blood so if you happen to
be a charge blade user this is really
nice I personally myself am NOT a charge
blade user I'm more of a dual blades and
longsword type guys so this really
doesn't fit my style but regardless it
is a rarity aid Dante's devil sword it
is the last little category at the
bottom it requires two red orbs and an
jeunesse gem in Oregon gem in 40 oast
remains to craft so it's pretty
difficult or pretty very expensive as
well just based off what it has it has
720 attack of blue sharpness no affinity
and 150 Thunder damage with the file
type being impact into level 1
decorations lots and
it is level 8 it does have one
augmentation slot if you happen to use
it now I'm not it like I said I'm not a
charge blade guy so any charge blade
users can tell me if this is actually
worth it I was told that the ignition
greatsword was one of the better
versions to use if you're a greatsword
user but at least in terms of this it
doesn't really look like it but I might
just be wrong so I'd love to know in the
comments below
but either way guys it's going to be the
end of the video today guys hope
hopefully you guys did enjoy that and
now you know how to get Dante's Armour
and the new charged blade that comes
with him elective video if you did enjoy
really does help me out subscribers we
knew I have lots of solo guys especially
on the higher tier monsters of Monster
Hunter so you could definitely check
that out in my channel if you do need
help with some of those monsters but I
need to farm it we need to kill them in
general it's entirely up to you you can
check those out if you want I also have
how-to guides and tips on how to get new
outfits or anything else that's new I
even have a guide on wolf to Roth which
did really well so think it goes for the
support on that video really does really
do appreciate it my two most recent
videos are gonna be on screen if you
guys do wanna check that out and with
that guys hope it'd be great rest your
day
thank you guys for the love and support
on the last video and hopefully on this
one too and I'll see you guys later
peace out